pour atteindre l'objectif de 150 000
nouveaux logements sociaux par an fixés
par François Hollande pendant sa
campagne la ministre Cécile Duflot a
proposé la semaine dernière un
renforcement de la loi SRU la loi de
solidarité et de renouvellement urbain
jusqu'à présent en Île-de-France les
communes de plus de 1500 habitants
devaient avoir au moins 20% de logements
sociaux la ministre souhaite voir ce
chiffre augmenter de 5 points ou en sont
les communes sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines petit tour
d'horizon en chiffres la barrière arrive
en tête des 7 communes suivie de près
par trappes et Manille les hameaux
Manille ou deux projets immobiliers
comportant des logements sociaux sont
prévus allez des Capucines et rue
Gabriel Péri Guyancourt se place en
quatrième position 230 nouveaux
logements sociaux devraient sortir de
terre prochainement à Villeroy Sud au
niveau de la ferme de Châteauneuf et sur
l'emplacement de l'ancienne école Paul
Langevin
ils seront mélangés avec des habitats
classiques afin de favoriser la mixité
sociale la commune de Guyancourt a
d'ailleurs indiqué dans son PLU que tout
projet de construction de 60 logements
ou plus doit comporter 50% de logements
sociaux et l'encourt
Montigny-le-Bretonneux sont au coude à
coude Voisins-le-Bretonneux quant à elle
arrive bonne dernière c'est la seule
commune à ne pas respecter les 20% de
logements sociaux obligatoires les
sanctions encourues jusqu'à leur
pourrait être multipliées par 5 avec la
nouvelle loi qui sera étudiée à
l'Assemblée nationale à partir du 24
septembre